well i think the evidence is pretty
clear you've got
about 130 000 troops massing on the
ukrainian border there's all sorts of
other uh
signs that show that there are serious
preparations for
an invasion and we've gotta we've gotta
respect that we gotta we gotta realize
that this is a very very dangerous
difficult situation we are on the edge
of a of a precipice but there is still
time for president putin to step back
and what we're urging is for everybody
to engage in dialogue for a conversation
uh to take place and uh for the russians
to avoid what i think everybody
certainly everybody in the uk can see
would be a disastrous mistake disastrous
for for russia do you think an invasion
could be hours days away
the signs are as you've heard from
president biden that
they're at least planning
for something that could take place as
early as in the next 48 hours
that is
extremely uh concerning where we what we
need to do is make sure that president
putin understands
the economic consequences the political
consequences of doing this and i think
what needs to happen is that the world
needs to learn the lesson of 2014. if
you remember russia took uh eastern
ukraine they took crimea but we didn't
really do enough to divest to move away
from dependence on russian hydrocarbons
and what i think all european countries
need to do now is you know get nordstrom
out of the bloodstream get the get that
uh yank out that uh that
hypodermic
drip feed of russian hydrocarbons that
is keeping
so many european economies going we need
to find alternative sources of energy
and we need to get ready to impose some
very very severe economic consequences
on on russia do you agree with the
defense secretary that there is a whiff
of munich in the air and if so who is
trying to appease president putin i
think it's very important that
we all stand together and
that we we show a united front
particularly when it comes to to
economic sanctions and the uk as you
know has been uh in the lead in bringing
the uh our allies together so that
there's a a tough package of of
sanctions but also what about
appeasement is somebody trying to
appease
i think that it's very very important
that uh the the west should stand united
and particularly that nato should stand
united and and it is and it's been
really encouraging to see the way
countries have pulled together but
you're not endorsing those comments
but what i'm saying is that it's
important uh for the west to stand
together and i think i think the defense
secretary is absolutely right to say it
is very important that we've got to be
strong and we've got to be resolute and
we've got to be united
is there no deal with president putin
that would be preferable to war
i think that
it's very important that we have a
dialogue that we have a conversation but
glenn you know what we can't do is
trade away
the
sovereign
rights of the ukrainian people to aspire
to nato membership that's something that
was a massive gain for our world
remember what happened in 1990 we had a
europe holding free countries could
decide their own futures we can't we
can't bargain that away it's for the
ukrainian people and you've got no plans
to travel to moscow yourself
i'm going to be doing everything i can
to
to help the diplomatic process and i'll
be talking to
various leaders including including joe
biden
very soon